[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to channel
awesomes orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world in
pop culture and entertainment news
I'm Heather Ruth and I'm Ayanna Wayne
and this is your news for Monday October
9th so I made it back unscathed you guys
defeated the Smith even defeated a few
Klingons but I'm back this week so just
in time for New York Comic Con weekend
now we are filming this before the
weekend is over so there will be
definitely some things that we missed
and we apologize we will get them to you
next week in the meantime here's the
things we found to talk about for this
week first of all we finally got a
trailer for The Runaways last week I
talked about the stills but this week we
got a trailer and honestly I was a
little disappointed by it like I've been
very excited about everything else
that's coming out about this and the
trailer just seemed kind of lackluster
like an average trailer I feel like if
you didn't read the comics you might be
like oh okay
maybe I'll check that out I didn't read
the series and so I personally wasn't
necessarily drawn in to watch it from
this specific trailer so yeah which is
unfortunate yeah that's wonderful I
promise I promise you guys it's
wonderful there were some little things
that you would notice if you had read
the comic you know we saw some spell
book action a little hot second of old
laces nose in there so it was pretty
interesting if you've read the comics
but I'm hoping that a next trailer might
be more interesting to draw more
possible viewers in and that's gonna be
on Hulu starting on November 21st the
superhero trailer I'm most excited for
right now is definitely the Netflix
original series raising Deon
this looks super heartfelt story of a
single mother raising a child who has
superpowers it looks like he has
multiple different powers and abilities
and I'm really excited about this
filming style it's very raw and there
looks almost like found-footage type of
stuff if the mother documenting her
child's progression with his powers it's
a great idea and I love this little
rulebook she even makes for her son to
kind of make sure he's using his powers
when he's supposed to or certain powers
when he should when he should be it
looks cute funny heartfelt I'm very
excited it's even produced by Michael B
Jordan yeah I mean it caught my interest
the minute I saw the trailer so I am
very excited about it kind of right
right in the hype train on that one I'm
gonna watch the heck out of it it's so
excited that's gonna be on Netflix again
but also has a companion comic that you
can go to their website will list the
lit website here for you to check out as
well yeah another trailer that's related
to a graphic novel that we saw was puppy
and got an exclamation point and
everything happy it's gonna be a sci-fi
series and it's based around a story of
this ex-cop he's like a dishonored
ex-cop who for some reason can't die
he turns hitman because he realizes hey
I can't die might as well just do
whatever I want but then one day he does
dine and then he's brought back to life
in the ambulance but when he's brought
back to life he meets happy who is an
imaginary unicorn of a little girl who
has been kidnapped so I guess they go on
this grand adventure to find the little
girl who has been kidnapped but just
because it's a little girl in the
Unicorn doesn't mean that's meant for
children no no the graphic novel is very
graphic it's very intense and it looks
like the show is gonna have that same
kind of intensity and humor um so this
is not for children but it looks just
bonkers it looks in saying I might check
it out I'm not I'm not sure I didn't
read the graphic novel but it does look
just crazy enough to be funny yeah so
Christopher Meloni looks hilarious but
also Patton Oswalt as happy look just
sounds great
like he's so funny so I will definitely
be checking that out yeah good cast
might as well um so that drops on
December 6th on sci-fi channel yeah we
also had a trailer drop for electric
ringg this series looks very similar to
the concept of a black mirror it's going
to be a 10 episode series of standalone
episodes it's all sci-fi looks like it's
talking about human experience some
technology maybe some robots the cast is
huge and it looks insane and if it's
anything like black mirror I mean this
will also be streaming on Amazon though
not Netflix so there's gonna be some
some button heads maybe yes lots of
different streaming services come out
with lots of different things um and
another streaming service is YouTube's
bread and they just showed a trailer for
Dwayne Johnson's lifeline which actually
seems really interesting I haven't
really heard much about this but there's
a private company the premise of it is
there's a private company that kind of
has access to time travel so they are
hired by people to save their loved ones
in the future so if they know that
someone's going to die they can send an
agent to the Future to save that person
and it seems like the drama revolves
around the main agent saves a girl from
jumping off a building and then this
whole tangled web of intrigue the cut
happens because they find out that the
agent is the reason that her father is
dead but the agent was there to save his
wife and there's all this moral
complexity to like who owns the rights
to time travel and why do certain people
get to be saved if they have enough
money to save these people it looks
pretty interesting and that's coming out
pretty soon October 11 yeah again it's
Dwayne Johnson's lifeline yeah I
definitely very intrigued by this series
it sounds like a very interesting
concept and YouTube red is really
stepping up their quality content as
well so that's always good in movie news
we also had a trailer for replicas with
my boy Keanu Reeves very excited for
this one the casting again looks very
well if for this but Keanu gets to be a
scientist
who sort of is able to clone people but
as robots little West world's little
replicant from Blade Runner action for
you so it it starts by him finding out
that his wife and child have died in
this crash and he uses this technology
that has been disbanded to bring them
back as AI basically and so of course
they're gonna get hunted down you know
the classic tale of humans and robots it
looks very interesting and I'll
definitely be checking it out
not so action-packed for a normal camera
film oh okay yeah I can say the world
needs more Keanu Reeves action movie
most excellent another movie trailer
that we got this weekend that I am
beyond hype for guys Pacific Rim Wow I'm
so excited I can't even words words are
just escaping a rage you like no idea
robot I am so excited for this
I loved the new mech designs that we saw
even gipsy danger has a whole new look a
couple new weapons
it looks amazing but again I just love
giant robots so the mechs are the
jaegers that's what they're called in
this universe
I hope the jaegers fighting the kaijus
they're back oh my gosh such pretty
action Johnny boy Yaga has a mustache
what I mean oh I'm so excited it looks
like it's gonna be a super fun action
movie which is everything I wanted out
of this and again I've said this before
I know the original Pacific Rim didn't
get amazing praise but I loved it
because I like hyeju's I like Max mm-hmm
I like I just like the concept I'll be
honest I didn't see the first Pacific
Rim and after seeing this trailer I was
in I was ready to see this one no it was
really well edited trailer I liked their
song choice ever everything looks really
action II and really cool mech looks so
I gotta say I was I was pulled in it was
well done trailer good it's what you
want in the trailer you just followed it
up with the film yes
I hope that all lit up with the filler
just as hyped as I am cuz I am so
excited okay let's talk about what I'm
hyped for okay for this we got a poster
apparently they got some footage of the
con but as of this taping we haven't
seen it so our poster for that's right
that's right Batman ninja full feature
anime he looks super cool in the poster
and it's going to be Bruce Wayne Batman
in time travels somehow into medieval
Japan cool concept
cool idea the design seat team sounds
awesome
it's Takashi Okazaki who did the
character designed for Afro Samurai and
then it's directed by jump a Mizzou sake
who did the Jojo Joker's are even yes so
cool cool team definitely excited for it
I'll be honest I think it could have
been done without Bruce wayne/batman
that's my personal opinion
I'm allowed it but also if it's gonna be
in medieval Japan why not just do a new
Batman who knows his backstory you could
explore that is it the same backstory
and all of a sudden we have a Japanese
Batman come on that sounds awesome
we have enough white guys in Asia very
army but I'm very excited for this
feature I will definitely be watching
this I mean come on so very excited for
this and I hope we get some leaked
footage come on yeah I want to see it I
want to see yeah especially it sounds
like there are other villains who are
transported as well like Harley and pink
and I believe so I definitely want to
see those outfits right I mean that
sounds great cool so I think that's
gonna be it from us this week boy could
you believe they didn't tell us that
so-and-so was gonna happen this weekend
can you imagine this crazy trailer that
dropped this other stuff contents here I
have no idea what else happens so we're
gonna leave you until next week how they
reckon people find you on social media
you can find me on Twitter at Heather
ruse Instagram at a truce or twitch
twitch TV slash others and as usual you
can find me on Facebook at Ayanna Wade
or everywhere else at awesome ion
that's gonna be it from us in the
meantime can you beat us up
[Applause]
you